if the prime minister really believes
that more needs to be done can he tell
us exactly what he will order his
chancellor to do to help the millions of
families who are facing a 700 pound
price hike this friday yeah prime
minister uh mr speaker i i thank him uh
very much and uh uh he is uh he's i
think he's an an error in what he says
about events last night but he is like
me a living testament to the benefits of
a moderation uh in all things
mr speaker
and uh i can i can assure him i can
assure him that we are we are getting
that this week for instance uh to get to
his point uh what's happening actually
is that the living wage is going up
again uh by record amounts and thanks to
what the chancellor has done uh we are
putting 9.1 billion pounds uh into
helping people up and down the country
and what i might respectfully suggest is
actually i think the the scottish
nationalist government with whom as i
say we work increasingly well i think
the thing they could focus on of
long-term prosperity of scotland is the
educational system where i'm sad to see
where i i'm sad to see i'm sad to see
scotland's once glorious record uh
falling behind
blackfin
what a load of absolute baloney
mr speaker the prime minister is
dangerously out of touch
food banks are warning that people are
having to choose their food
based on whether they can afford the gas
to boil it
families are having to choose what rooms
to heat or whether they can turn on the
heating at all
some in the tory cabinet clearly believe
that better weather means that they can
happily sit on their hands and do
nothing until next winter they obviously
don't get or don't care that in many
parts of scotland the weather will
barely reach above freezing over the
next week yep the chancellor thinks he's
200 pound loan which is forcing people
into energy debt
is somehow a solution but it clearly
isn't so before the prime minister and
his chancellor go off on their easter
holidays will they at very least turn
this lawn into a grant and finally put
some cash into people's pockets when
they need it right now
[Music]
i thank you but of course
we are doing everything that we can the
the 9.1 billion the cold the cold
weather payments and he's right he's
right to draw attention uh to the
problem uh mr speaker and we are we are
making making a huge investment in
supporting uh people right now and
another billion by the way through the
household support fund uh to help
vulnerable uh help vulnerable families
but mr speaker when he talks about the
cost of energy in in scotland how
absolutely preposterous uh that the
scottish nationalist party uh should
still be opposed uh to the use of any of
our uh native hydrocarbons in this
country uh with with the result with the
result that we actually have to we that
the europeans are importing uh oil and
gas from putin's russia
mr speaker totally absurd